sonic tractor beams use loudspeakers to
create high pressure shapes out of sound
acoustic Holograms that can hold rotate
and even move objects in midair but for
years researchers have struggled to
levitate objects larger than half the
wavelength of the sound using a single
acoustic vortex researchers have only
been able to levitate teeny tiny objects
about one point six millimeters wide
larger items spin uncontrollably and are
ejected now a team of engineers has
figured out how to levitate objects more
than ten times that size using a hundred
and ninety-two loudspeakers they created
two vortexes that pulse and alternating
bursts of a few milliseconds each this
technique stops the objects spinning
which makes them more stable and allows
the researchers to levitate objects
larger than the wavelength of the sound
it may be a while before such beams can
be put to practical use but in the
meantime scientists say that with more
powerful speakers they might be able to
hold and even control astronauts in
zero-gravity